اخفق الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب الامريكي
في انتخابي رئيسا له في دوره تصويت الاولى
ضمن جوله الافتتاحيه من التصويت وذلك
للمره الاولى منذ 100 عام ولم يتمكن
المرشح الاقوى النائب عن ولايه كاليفورنيا
كذبتي من نيللي دعم الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب الذي سيطر عليه
الديمقراطيون بعد الانتخابات النصفيه في
نوفمبر اذا مجلس النواب الذي سيطر عليه
الجمهوريون وحصل مكارثي على ثلاثه اصوات
مقابل 2002 10 لزعيم الاقليه الديمقراطيه
هذا ولجا النواب الامريكيون الى جوله
ثانيه من التصويت
هذا الاخفاق لا يخفي حقيقه سيطره
الجمهوريين اليوم رسميا على مجلس النواب
لينهو بذلك رسميا افضل ايام بيضا في الحكم
الرئيس والديمقراطي الذي لم يجد اي صعوبه
في تمرير اجنده منذ تنصيبه قبل عامين
سيبدا من اليوم بالاضطرار الى التعامل مع
الواقع الجديد الصعب تقول فورم بوليسيه
انه بغض النظر عن هويه رئيس مجلس النواب
الجديد الا ان الامر اشبه بشوكه في خاصرت
بيضا
الاولويه الان او البندق الاولويه القصوى
لدى الجمهوريين هو التحقيق في انسحاب
القوات الامريكيه الفضيه من افغانستان
والفشل في اجلاء المدنيين متعددين
الجنسيات من كابول مثلا النائب الجمهوري
مايكل صادق تقريرا قاسيا حول هذا الانسحاب
حمل فيه بايدا مسؤوليات الفشل في تنفيذ
اتفاق الانسحاب الذي تم في عهد الامر
الاكثر اهميه ان مايكل هو المرشح الاوفر
حظا لرئاسه لج الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس
النواب اي انه سيسعى لتضييق الخناق على
بايرن تقول لافورين بوليسي ايضا ان مسؤولي
اداره بيدن الذين افلتوا من الاستجواب حول
الانسحاب خلال سيطره الديمقراطيين على
الكونجرس سيخضعون الان لجلسات استماع
طويله
[موسيقى]
العطره الثانيه التي سيضعها الجمهوريون في
طريق هي كيفيه تقديم المساعده لاوكرانيا
مثلا السنه الجمهوريه عن ولايه اوهايو
جديفانس قال بعباره صريحه انه لا يهتم حقا
بما يحدث لاوكرانيا ثم هناك مشكله اخرى
لم يتوقفوا عند هذا الحد بل ان هناك نيه
للوصول لما هو ابعد فمثلا يستهدفون الان
النيل من مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
كريستوفري الذي يقود تحقيقا بشان وثائق
ترامب سريه بدا الحديث من اندي بيجز
النائب عن اريزونا الذي طالب في وقفه
تمويل الاجهزه الفاسده على حد وصفه ومنها
الاف بي اي
الناس
[تصفيق]
الامنيسا
في المكتب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]